oh go ahead baby we're gonna say though
so I have an alter ego for that I gave
my dog my dog's names goby but her alter
ego is a stripper named Trina Michelle
Corpus Christi she moved to Atlanta
because that's where it's a hub of like
sugaring and being a stripper right you
know so I call her Trina Michelle and
like Trina Michelle you got to pack your
[ __ ] bag blah blah and he's in the room
and he's losing his mind cuz he's like
my daughter is not a stripper like
losing his mind about it so we got into
the discussion of you know what you
would do if you know your daughter is
you know mid nineteen twenty and she's
like you know with that I'm not gonna
like stop College I'm gonna continue but
I like being an exhibitionist
I'd like the acrobatic nature of it I'm
gonna be a stripper and he lost his
[ __ ] mind over it if I have a
daughter she could be a stripper I want
to be able to like if my daughter is a
performance artist I want to support
okay let's suppose this let's make it
you guys so we're gonna go we're gonna
go we're gonna go we're gonna use
they're a couple of my girlfriend's are
my daughter's a stripper you are we're
all gonna go watch her no no listen it's
your vision you guys are gay dads and
you adopted me okay
I'm 19 I'm 20 and wait wait wait yes
wait
me and David are gay yeah you're gay
dads yeah yeah so we watch beauty in the
beasts together yes yeah could I just
say this
then I have to be the bottom you can't
know he'll crazy drive bro oh yeah yeah
I have to be yeah I was I have to be the
tell you would you still be a power
bottom
[Laughter]
oh we do 69 standing up right and he has
my ankles no listen I don't want to do
that but I will just see if that would
work with the clothes on to see if you
could be the upper body strength oh
that's a good excuse I told you this is
the best hides everything yeah you have
upper button all I
I saw you buy that new workout you're on
this like new weight-loss thing yeah but
that's all legs the upper body Oh create
an apparatus where I'm like going to
beauty okay anyways that's might be you
guys are gay dad you adopted me I'm
gonna tell you this is my speech to you
dad dad's dad and dad I graduated
valedictorian from you know what's so
interesting every time in these
scenarios it's like this person has to
be the highest pinnacle of human being
you know I mean yeah I'm gonna be the
stripper but I cured cancer bring it
down lay the scene out then so remember
David alright just visualize right
we've been together for describe this I
know we've been together for 20 years
right
we've must have [ __ ] you and I eighty
thousand times right I see this I but
you've also never stepped foot in a
strip club because obviously you're both
yeah but you and I have really eaten
everything okay yeah and but we love
each other too in this scenario okay and
this is our daughter we love our
daughter
alright what's going on with your face
right now because at this point if
that's true I don't give a [ __ ] what she
does
I've eaten ass every day nobody in our
private life nobody in the world knows
that in when we closed doors like we're
like we were sure sure stalkers know we
take K curve we have button-up just tuck
it into our pans we have belts Buddha
where we have briefcases what are your
jobs are we gonna work I need jobs I'm
an executive at Enterprise Rental what
no he's a key maker
he's like a lock what is the world the
key maker but he has his own business
because he came into my business right
right years ago yeah ha early eighties
you know I walked in anyway so we have
regular we have regular jobs so and we
met in the early 80s and obviously we're
gay so we can't have so we adopt this
beautiful baby well guess what this girl
every level with all our hearts okay we
take it to like Disneyland we actually
created a thing you and I bought a real
doll right yeah we've got a real doll
and we filled the titty with milk so
that she could have real breast milk oh
okay so I could have a mother experience
like we really talked our little baby
into the little cradle right and then we
go to our room the door we lock the door
just in case the baby can already smell
the room and it smells terrible the
vigils are bringing a smell it's a four
hour [ __ ] fest all the baby hears is
this
right how they and the alarm clock goes
up shirts we took in our pants and bye
sweetie
and we go to work so now we raise his
kids at school private school this in
private school right and you know yeah
and at 19 she comes to us and this is
what she says go ahead I know I told you
guys that I was planning on go to med
school I still plan on it but I have
this side of me that's just very you
know exhibitionist I love you know I've
been a gymnast my whole life I love
dance I love we used to love baby we
used to love coming to you you watch you
showed me all those articles yeah
remember sweetie remember I do baby yeah
yeah I'm gonna be my own character yeah
I love your little accent baby anyway
you guys I just really wanna be a
stripper and I want to see what that
life's about I wanted to make extra
money and I think that with my sex
appeal and her was my sexual openness
stop please stop that's fine you can do
whatever you want with your life
but I pay for your cell phone we're
cutting up I can pay for that myself if
I start cutting
of course hold on sweetie
hey can you go get my butt hole in the
room with
[Laughter]
you're not we're not paying for medical
school and you're not you're not doing
that why not because we provide you with
all the money that you would need you're
going to medical school you're not doing
that it's a will then become become a
dancer like or will okay you can go to
class we'll take take you to class any
kind of class that you want if you want
to do a live show but I like the
seediness of the strip club I like that
atmosphere well then at this point
there's nothing I can do for you baby go
go live your life and don't call home Oh
Diggs can I put my real dad yeah okay
cool for me it would be okay it's a
little unfair for you to spring it up on
us like that out of nowhere yeah you
didn't have a conversation with me about
this previously your favorite father and
I personally think that that's really
offensive and on top of that if you want
to live your life however the hell you
want then you can do it without taking
money from us now if you want to follow
our rules then of course we can support
you in that I will always love you but
you are now a [ __ ] that is what I'm
building my body for sex you can dance
all you want [ __ ] you could do it with
your clothes on what the [ __ ] does that
have to do with the team now daddy's
angry yeah I've seen you guys be a
certain way you guys have been nudists
your whole life and you we're not
noticed we've closed the door behind
closed boy doesn't matter yeah we are
cloaked God can't even see us yeah God
can see us I'm a good father
I eat ass all day I don't care at all
every time I drink I never shares a cup
with you yeah okay what if what is now
and the girls but also just in this
scenario once a year we have a special
in this scenario once a year we have a
special night on our anniversary Gill
bits comes over hey what that boys
hey uncle Cal okay so what if what if
let's say I didn't want to be a stripper
but it's 17 in like dad you know what
I want to sell my virginity online and I
want to give the money to like I want to
give it to charity [ __ ] what charity is
this get the [ __ ] out of here you are
going to be sold to the sex world and
also I also kind of just say that you
would never if with us as your parents
you would never even think about because
you know us you would know what our
reaction would be it was our stripper
daughter so stupid you don't know what's
in my DNA is a genetic I mean a DNA
thing I mean I think that there are
people of women who are hyper sexual and
I really want to park
I want to say you're not your health bar
no there's an element of showmanship and
being that you what if your boyfriend or
whatever your [ __ ] what if she wants to
parlay that into a business down the
road where she's like suburban white
with all night like this is you you know
what I do I can't even [ __ ] collect
my heels properly I know how much money
are you making though let's say off the
business or me as a stripper off the
whole business altogether realistic
let's say I take home okay cash okay
120km
of course then go ahead that's accordion
way money over morals all right how
about this would you you you're let's
see you're really hard yeah would you
that's all it is is lap dances and
stripping no it's down the road I really
like the performance aspect of it I want
to parlay it into an and a business
where I can teach women and you could
okay but you can strengthen this is as
long as you don't [ __ ] yes I'm not into
prostitution or porn no porn I just want
to dance daddy
you could dance with your clothes on is
all I'm saying what I'm thinking right
now
yeah is that I just don't like people
objectifying you in that type of way
yeah and I think that if you could use
this versus this it's a lot more
impressive you could do whatever you
want
doors I'm completely okay with that and
I love you no matter what but if you
become a stripper and we're walking in
the grocery store I might ignore you
okay daddy but I have an argument to
that what if to certain degree I like
being objectified what if I enjoy that
voyeur aspect when people are watching
me and looking at me just beyond I don't
want to intellectualize this I want to
be a woman with tits and ass that's
moving around and a man salivating over
me it empowers me down why is it so
that's so unfair that I have a such a
dumb daughter life is so unfair for us
[Laughter]
not me I often think about how I would
approach it if I had a daughter like
would you do yeah I'd be really torn
because I want to empower her and make
no word of Allah to God I know you
kalila there is no way that you would
agree to what look I know you the only
reason that I'm the reason why you
didn't do it the reason why you didn't
do it because you're you know your mom
Limor and your mom no my mom's sister I
don't think they would I don't think
your mom would sign up for I look at
awesome she's at the top of her game
porch she's intelligent she's she's just
the best at what she does awesome but
dude have you seen her videos but she
enjoys it yeah two dicks coming out of
her ears what she I mean she's all I
love also she's been we did our podcast
early on I love her as a person she can
she's family I want to share a while
okay but she when she talks about it
she's always been a hyper sexual person
and she's always enjoyed she I know what
she was a kid I know so how can you take
away if it bothers you but doesn't
bother her why why is it I'm eating - I
think it's but we're allowed to be
bothered by it just like you have
everyone choice to choose what you want
to do I'm allowed to be bothered by it
as well yeah so I'm glad that you know
if my daughter did talk to me about it
that's dope
but once again you sprung it on to me
out of nowhere I could have helped you
out yeah mmm if you wanted to start a
business we could have made money
together now you want to make money by
yourself without your parents
yeah I think you're more looking at it
okay bird the safety aspect of it being
a man and knowing just the overall
seediness of well for me it's like this
uh I grew up with them on that's very
strong very outspoken and people respect
my mom because of those aspects guys are
[ __ ] dogs they will only see you for
that as smart as you think that you are
doesn't mean that these guys will see
you that way too
yeah so if you are if you want to
commend that type of respect and the
same thing goes for men too if a guy's a
[ __ ] ditz and all years is buff
that's all women CMS - it works both
ways the reason why I got sober at 7:18
okay it wasn't because of the fact that
like I mean I did have like a spiritual
awakening and I was so very desperate
but I also saw my parents and the way
they reacted and how destroyed and hurt
they are and it's like I you know I'm
very influenced by how they feel you
know about things and so and I've been
very you know intuitive in that way of
like how they react to my decisions I
think that are sensitive to them yeah
and I think that by me going I wanted to
stand up and then reaction to that was a
little that that I could go you know
what that they're delusional but in
terms of like things like hey you know
I'm addicted to drugs and and seeing the
reaction you know I I have to be
sensitive to that as a son you know and
I hope that my daughter would be
sensitive to that fact but you're acting
as if you know you're not sensitive to
us know I love you I respect you I did
notice inner desire there's no way you
have it the way you're approaching us
just out of nowhere okay I don't know
where maybe a little guy have you just
got naked in the kitchen out of nowhere
that's like of course I knew this one
yeah you know and then for some reason
she's 17 her lip is like hanging into
the [ __ ] everyday cucumber Missy
[Laughter]
either I try the de cucumber kimchi I
never can or I'm hungry and I'm tired
cuz I have only three hours time what
the [ __ ] are we doing with time time for
a question where were we at over 110
okay we're long overdue okay so I'm
hungry I'm sorry okay don't ever okay
I'll give it you're a great gas by the
way yeah it flows so easily with you and
on your first repeat yes next I mean
rent we have a show idea we kalila and
have a show Eddie you're in our shop
it's a Korean family show but it's two
gay dads so this was the introduction I
knew it already membership for 24 hour
fitness I'm hopeful vice with kalila he
followed me on Twitter he his big deal
he's Genghis Khan yeah also he's Doctor
Strange go ahead
[Music]